dude  dude dude  all right mark hamill put this tweet up  today  this is pin tweet and if i looked at it  i was like  oh wait yeah i'm in that thumbnail oh  that's mixed reactions video that's  right  mixer if you haven't subscribed mixed  reactions make sure to subscribe he puts  together wonderful compilations  seriously and like i mean  i'm in that video several people i know  are in that video a lot of people who i  watch on youtube who do reactions as  well  are in that video  but i'm in that video  and to know that he watched mine and  john's reaction  oh thanks eric and you're crying for  editing that video  oh that just what a great way to end the  year  i'm so happy about that